hello everyone and welcome to a very
very strange game from the video world
team championship it is team Spain
versus Team France it is David Anthony
and it features a moment that I don't
think uh ever happened in Chess at at a
level quite as this one because uh okay
you you've had like a world champion Mrs
mating one you've had someone miss a
fork you've had uh I don't know in the
in the uh of French uh French
Championship I think last year or this
year we had that made in 10 moves that
was absolutely incredible the queen
sacrificed with the double bishop
checkmate but that's all something that
you can overlook this what happens here
is like uh I don't know how to how to
set or what the equivalent would be uh
it's like it's like if you were walking
with a friend uh down the street and
there was a an elephant appears out of
nowhere and you don't see it okay so
that can be possible maybe you maybe
something happened in your head but that
both of you missed the elephant that's
really really strange but what's even
stranger is that in this game it's not
like it was like a a gray gray Road and
a grave pavement and the gray Everything
Green then a gray elephant like in this
game the elephant is Pink
uh so what I mean by this is uh what you
will what you will see now so uh has the
white pieces and he opens with D4 sorry
about that
replies with Knight to F6 we have C4 E6
Knight to C3 and D5 so a standard
Queen's Gambit declined uh Bishop to G5
and now uh Bishop to E7 the Modern Line
we have E3 H6 and now Bishop to H4 here
a Musa castles we have Knight to F3 and
pawn to B6 now preparing to think after
the light Square Bishop Queen to B3 and
now Bishop to B7 so again this is all
very well known stuff nothing new
Happening Here Bishop captures Bishop
capture C capture C captures uh and now
Rook the D1 there are like 200 top level
games in this exact same position uh
Rook T8 Bishop to E2 we have C6 and now
uh castles by David Anton we have Knight
to D7 uh and uh it's a very known uh
very well known position it has been
reached many times mostly it's been
played uh some 20 30 years ago for
example timan had this against posky
fortunately headed against flega
and in all of those games Rook fte1 was
played but here we have H3 by David
Anton which is the strongest move
recommended by the engine so obviously
he made or rather uh it depends on how
long you let the engine run it the
engine uh can't decide between rook fte1
and H3 so it's a it's a definitely a
different approach the I've always
played before and it is now as of move
14 that we have a completely new game uh
Bishop back to E7 you could uh also try
some other stuff it all depends maybe
you want to bring the Knight to f8 the
G6 or maybe Knight to f8 at H7 to G5
maybe we want to play G6 Bishop to G7 uh
all depends on how you want to play this
the bishop is actually nicely placed
here The Rook is coming to C8 at some
point you want to execute C5 at some
point so those are all ideas uh it all
depends in what order do you want to
accomplish them so Bishop to E7 first
uh we have E4 now striking in the center
now Shifting the bishop to this diagonal
wouldn't really do all that much as the
pawn will come to E5 so here we have
Knight F the E6 E5 and Knight the H7
with Bishop to D3 and now Knight to f8
so the Knight does come to f8 only it
takes a bit of a longer route we have
Knight to E2 and now Knights the E6 a
beautiful Square for that um a dark
knight and now Bishop to F5 also uh
maybe to consider is Bishop B1 this
diagonal is available to white but uh
David Anton says that he would like to
trade this bishop for a night uh it's a
beautifully strong Bishop but this
Knight is also fairly strong and of
course David Anton knows what he's doing
uh Bishop to fate we have Bishop
captures an E6 Rook captures and E6 and
now Rook F the E1 uh Rook back to E8 and
now Knights the H2 we have Fantasy 5
striking against the white strong Center
here and Ponte F4 improving your your
Center as you know C captures on D4 can
happen at any time
Rook the C8 by black and now Queen to G3
and the queen is incredibly powerful
here if the spawn let's say goes to F5
to F6 black will have a lot of problems
with Queen to D7 Knight the G for now
already with a dangerous threat Knight
to F6 check will win the black queen
king the h8 and now King to H2 we have
Pawn to A5 and now Knight the E3 adding
more more pressure now the Knight can
come to F5 also the the Knight Will
nicely support the pawn to F5 push we
have A4 and now D captures on C5 and
this is a very important in between move
uh it's not even an in-between move it's
it's the main move of the line but uh
point is that if you play F5 black has a
very nice counter with C captress on D4
and now look at this Knight captures on
the four Rook captures on E5 and you've
given up all of your advantage Queen
captures and E5 of course is impossible
because of Bishop D6 winning the queen
as the king and queen are so
conveniently placed on the same diagonal
but okay after a 4D captures on C5 first
by David Anton uh Rook captures on C5
and now Pawn to A3 we have rooked the B5
going after the B2 Pawn Rook the D2
defending uh but now Bishop to C5 uh
putting uh pressure on the knight uh we
have Knight the D4 and now Bishop
captures and D4 we have Rook characters
and The Rook captures on B2 so musar
wins the B Pawn uh he now has very nice
control over the second Rank and also he
can go after that a pawn so what was uh
David Anton's idea in allowing this uh
well he plays Knight the C4 also to be
considered is just F5 F6 uh but okay
Knight the C4 attacking the rook and
also this is impossible because the
queen will be captured and your real
threat is because of course you you know
you're not capturing The Rook is
bringing the knights to D6 so Rook the
B3 attacking the White Queen Queen F2
and now Rook to f8
uh you know that the night is coming to
D6 so it's gonna be a fork uh Knight to
D6 and now Pawn to F6 the busting open a
white strong Center Queen to D2 and now
we have Bishop to C6 not allowing um
that Bishop to be captured we have Queen
to C2 now uh and F captures on E5 you
could also consider capturing the pawn
on E3 uh uh and then some like Rook to
B4 goes after the B6 Pawn but we have F
characters on E5 instead F captures and
only now Rook captures on A3 uh Queen to
G6 now getting the queen into the attack
and now we have Rook to F2 uh Rook to A2
uh was probably stronger here uh but uh
musar starts with Rook to F2 King the G1
now uh Rook to G4 will come at some
point so you might as well play right
away but he starts with King the G1 puts
pressure on The Rook now Rook a to A2
and now Rook the G4 now white has very
very strong pressure on the G7 Pawn the
queen has the defend it and on the other
hand black has a very strong pressure on
the second Rank and also if the Rook
moves uh well you can just start pushing
those past pawns and here we have Queen
to E7 a very nice try with D4 and it
makes sense you open up the Bishop's
diagonal you go after the G2 Pawn but
then you go into this Force line of E6
attacking Black's Queen where you can't
really capture the Knight if you capture
the Knight then Queen G7 is Checkmate
the queen has to cover the G7 Square so
here we would see a forced line of Rook
captures on G2 Rook captures Rook
captures with check Queen captures and
now Queen captures on D6 uh going for
Pawn to E7 and now Bishop to E8 this is
how you have to play it and now Queen to
E4 you would get this position where
black is down the exchange but black is
up three pawns so
uh it's hard to say black would probably
be the one pushing for the win here but
with perfect play uh should be a draw
instead he goes for Queen to E7 uh and
now we have Knight to F5 attacking the
queen putting even more pressure on that
G7 pawn and now you have to play it Rook
captures an F5 or maybe you don't you
can play Queen to f8 it's also a nice
move even better if you if you're asking
the engine uh but Rook captures on F5 is
a lot more fun so real captors Queen
captures and now Pawn to D4 again
opening up this diagonal uh and starting
to March your past Pawn down the board
we have E6 white does the same King to
G8 and now we have Rook the C1 putting
pressure on that Bishop Bishop to E8 and
the now comes Rook captures on D4 and
white is completely winning here uh if
white plays something like Rook to C8
it's uh instant resign there's no way to
contest this point is that whatever move
you make let's say you play Ponte A3
Queen G6 and how are you stopping this
there is no defense if you play King to
f8 just throw captors Queen captures and
now Queen captures on G7 will be
Checkmate so a pretty bad Miss for David
Anton he goes for Rook capture Sandy for
first which still uh he he's better but
this was just a forced win
um you know
right there but okay a rook to E2 now we
have Rook the E for Rook captures Queen
captures and now Pawn to A3 here he
gives black some chances as now those
pawns are Marching on the board Rook the
C8 uh and now Pawn to B5 we have Queen
to C6 threatening the bishop here and
just came to a fate defending the bishop
we have Queen to F3 with check King to
G8 and now Queen to C6
and this is not the the correct way to
to go after the pawn the correct way and
the one that wins you the tempo and it's
very interesting is Queen to H5 actually
and now after King to fade you play
Queen to F5 check and only after King to
G8 you play Queen captures on B5 because
now the king is on G8 so it's very much
different uh and the queen cannot
capture an E6 because the bishop would
hang on any eight in the game David
Anton gives up this valuable Tempo he
plays Queen to C6 King to f8 again
defends the bishop and now Queen
captures on B5 but now the king is not
on G8 the king is an f8 and he gives up
the E6 Pawn so king a queen captures an
E6 and now Queen to B4 with check Queen
to C5 uh is still much much stronger
because after Queen the C5 checking G8
Rook the A8 you will be able to stop the
pawn without any problems if Pawn to A2
there's Queen F2 and there's no way for
black to cause any any more trouble in
the game however after Queen to B for
check King to G8 we have rooked the A8
now but now comes Queen to E3 check
which would be impossible if the queen
was an F2 King H2 and now you just allow
black all a whole lot of checks Queen to
E5 checking to H1 Queen to A1 with
checking to H2 Queen to E5 with checking
to G1 and now Queen to E3 with Chair
King H1 Queen C1 check King H2 Queen to
C7 check and now King to G1 we have
Queen to C1 with check and now white not
satisfied with the draw because white
was better for the entire game even
though white is no longer better white
still wants to play for the win because
it's an equal position
uh Queen C2 Chuck King the E3 and now
comes Queen to C1 with check uh the best
way to to continue is A2 that's the way
you wanna you wanna Force this even
though it kind of hangs the bishop here
uh but after Rook capture 78 King H7 and
Rook to A8 you're still gonna Queen your
Pawn it's a queen to C1 check King
wherever A1 Queen and now even if uh or
uh even if uh you try something else uh
or okay after Queen to C1 check you
don't have to move your king you could
also play Queen to D2 uh still just Pawn
to A1 Queen and that's it uh it's uh
it's still a draw just real captures
Queen captures and however you want to
play this it's a draw uh but in the game
Queen to C1 check was played Queen to D2
blocking and now Queen to C5 with check
with Queen to D4 uh Queen to C6 and now
white is suddenly again completely
winning with Queen to E4 defending the
rook and forcing a trade because the
bishop on E8 is hanging and okay Queen
captures an E4 King captures and King to
F7 defending his Bishop Here and Now
Rook the A7 with check
uh we have King to F6 and now King the
F4 uh still not going uh for that A3
Pawn you could capture it but if you
play Rook captures on A3 then Bishop to
C6 with the check grabs the G2 pawn and
of course they both know then that then
the position is a draw so you first have
to tend to your king side King to F2 we
have G5 with track and now King to E3 we
have Pawn to H5 G3 and now Bishop to B5
with King to F2 and now Bishop to C4 uh
we have Rook captures on A3 okay the
pawn was never going to be saved but
white was just waiting for uh black to
put a bishop so so he will just capture
it one move before black pushes it all
the way to a A2 so Bishop to E6 with
Rook the A6 and now King Day five so the
position is completely winning for white
you just have to be very very precise
about it Rook day five with tracking F6
King to G2 Bishop to D7 and now King the
h do we have Bishop the E6 Rook the A4
and now Bishop to D7 attacking the rook
and we reach our spectacular position uh
from the thumbnail uh this is the moment
where the magic happens and it's hard to
it's hard to imagine something like this
even happened in an actual chess game in
a feeding world team championship game I
mean uh here uh Bishop to D7 this is
move 79 okay the players might be a bit
tired but these are absolute
professionals uh so I don't think we can
take that into consideration attacks the
rook and A4 and what do you think white
played here well you might consider
something like Rook A3 Rook A5 Rook D6
check Rook A7 Rook day eight uh any move
with the Rook like literally any move
with the Rook will be fine except like
these these three okay
but any move other than that will be
fine however here white played Ponte H4
absolutely incredible and uh it wasn't
uh all that uh a big of a Time trouble I
think David Anton had like 20 seconds on
the clock Jill musar had like a minute
on the clock so you know in Grand Master
terms that's an eternity uh and now you
would expect okay what's the point uh
he's just gonna grab the rook and uh
David and blunders the game but uh nope
Jill mustard just plays G captures on H4
he can play Bishop captures on A4 and
it's uh that's that's that but he plays
G captures on H4 and David Anton just
plays a rook capture 7 H4 and the game
continues with David Anton being
completely winning
so that's why I said that it's hard for
me to uh to even uh present this to you
because I have no idea what to compare
it with like that that pink elephant is
the best best I have like if if any of
you are following football there's a
there's a football World Championship
happening at the moment uh how would you
uh what what would be the football
equivalent uh of uh this happening in
football like well what we've just
witnessed in this game like what would
have to happen in football uh for it to
be uh equivalent uh I mean I have no
idea everybody yeah Bishop 37 was played
and now just H4 uh G captures and root
captures on H4 and the white went on to
win the game it took him some 40 more
moves but now it's merely a a you know a
technical thing uh not much to discuss
here black had to give up his one pawn
and then
uh I mean you know a bit of cat and
mouse play here and in the end uh black
hat to resign uh there we go uh not not
much not much to show you here from this
position this is basically where the
game ended so it was uh in this position
on 124 that the uh that the game Ended
as uh there was nothing more to be done
for julmussard so he resigned and uh
what what a win for David Anton I mean
uh can you imagine in a class in a
classical game you know in a world A
Team Championship uh match uh blundering
blundering an entire Rook like this this
is this does not happen even if you play
in a bar like this does not happen uh
and then your opponent just plays G
captures on H4 like uh an absolute case
of double blind as we've had cases like
this before but never quite like this
like there was always okay you missed a
fork you missed the mating too you
missed something there there was
something to miss you know the elephant
was hiding behind the tree or something
but not here I mean this is just we've
never had this
uh so yeah that's the game I hope you
guys enjoyed this and uh yeah I mean it
can happen I always say it can happen to
anyone it happens to you it happens to
them and it even happens in a feedy
world team championship game uh so I
really hope you guys enjoyed that I
would like to thank Carmen poliferoni of
ravishing reptiles YouTube Austin
wheeler Ahmed Yusuf and anub akihal for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of
defeated world team championship and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
uh thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day